how are you both doing doing well all
right I think I can tell you guys are
family members there's a little bit of a
similarity and cheekbones maybe so I
think the movie is incredible the only
thing I think it's missing is that your
dad wasn't wearing a cape because he is
a I don't want to curse but an effing
hero you know I mean it's unbelievable
what he did talk a little about what it
was like for the two of you watching it
for the first time and have you seen it
yet yet happy yeah we've been involved
with the film for almost two years so at
the script level at the post-production
level you know consulting on it so but
one thing to consult though it's one
thing to read the script it's another
thing for that visceral experience of
sitting in a darkened movie theater
watching the journey unfold yeah at
least I think yet no I it's it's an
irritable feeling and when it all comes
together with with with that those
visceral effects with the with the score
which is which is absolutely fantastic
and and of course their performances
it's it's really gratifying to see to
see it come together in a way that feels
familiar and true to us
sure well I'm one of the scenes that's
really powerful and it's not really a
spoiler but it's the it's being
portrayed as you two at the dinner table
with your mom and dad yeah when he's
getting ready to go to the moon and you
know she's demanding that you need to
talk to them how much is that because
it's always a balance of like what
really happened versus you're you're
making a movie right so what's it like
watching something like that do you is
it similar to what really happened is it
did it convey sort of that dynamic
between the two of them and you two we
yeah we did have a family meeting
it did happen at the dining room table
and and met and that is memorable for us
because we'd never had a meeting at the
dining room table right maybe the little
kitchen table where we always ate or you
know in the living room we never
actually sat down in our formal space
and had this meet up for holiday did it
except for yeah Thanksgiving and
Christmas dinner something like that so
so so that is exactly what happened
and and Rickon speak to you know what he
remembers of what what was said I don't
remember any specific you know dialogue
I just remember not being worried not
coming away and not being worried that
definitely said start and started out
the meeting by saying that
yeah we're confident in the mission but
you know we might not land you know
50/50 you know a lot of stuff has to go
right for that to happen well what we
think we're coming back but there is
some risk I mean he said that pretty
much the way Ryan said it
the only difference from the movie is I
didn't remember saying do you think
you're coming back because I didn't have
any doubt that he was coming back so I
wouldn't have asked that I was sure that
whatever happened they figure it out and
they'd be back because I was 12 so sort
of old enough to know what's going on
but not old enough to really get the
complexity of what they're trying to do
completely ryan's performance is just so
spectacular in this and he's he just
captures so much without saying he says
so much with saying so let him you know
what I mean was that the way your dad
was yes no accurate is that portrayal
that's very accurate good yeah I mean
Ryan totally nailed that that one dad he
didn't say a lot and he certainly didn't
initiate conversations that often but he
always listened very carefully and he
and he would think about what he wanted
to say and then he would say something
and usually what he said was was was
right on so definitely the scenes I mean
the thing that really enjoyed seeing
about it is sort of bringing out some of
the humor because that was really a
pretty funny guy and he had kind of dry
wit and throwing that stuff all the time
so the so the scenes where Ryan is doing
that I'm like yeah that's kind of pretty
much I think how dad would have said
that if he would have said that same
thing and when we looked at and we
looked at early version of the script
that was one of the things that we that
we said to Josh's
you know we got you got to get his sense
of humor in here because like people
don't know it and and it's really an
important part of who he was yeah I'm
listen Congrats movie as I said
spectacular I hope you get to watch it a
number of other times you don't have
been yeah yeah thanks so much
[Music]
[Music]